let's answer some audience questions
Aaron wrote in hey guys what are your
views on hair transplants and is it vain
to spend so much money on your cosmetic
appearance okay I don't know what your
views are generally on plastic and
cosmetic surgery Pat my view is the
following if there's something that is
really affecting you in a way where you
were feeling lack of self-confidence or
it is making you uncomfortable in public
I don't have any problem with people
getting the cosmetic procedure whether
it's surgery or something like hair
transplants or whatever if it's going to
make you feel better about your
appearance now where I there's a a gray
area between getting a procedure that
makes you feel better and more confident
about your appearance may be something
that for a long time has bothered you
versus when it starts to get into the
sort of obsessive body dysmorphia
constant plastic plastic surgery type of
thing like that for example Michael
Jackson had with constant surgeries to
his nose and so many other things where
the line is I don't know you know I know
people who have had nose jobs for
example and uh they forever like their
nose and they get a nose job and now
they're happy with their nose and
they're not looking at getting other
procedures done and it seems like it's a
sort of relatively well adjusted and
healthy thing uh that I I don't really
have a problem with that yet people are
happy with getting these sorts of
procedures i think there's no problem
with that whatsoever but i think for me
personally at least a line i would draw
is if you're getting some a procedure
done to just get you to a baseline level
maybe to like regain the hair that you
had before or so that you you look you
know similar to everyone else in a
certain way I would be okay with that
but if you start to look like an alien
because you had so many so much work
done that would just be too much for me
so you're saying is you're much more uh
positive about if people have
experienced some change to their
appearance whether it's for example hair
loss and then getting hair transplants
to get back to the hair that they had at
one point or I'm guessing and I'm I'm
sort of assuming here if someone has for
example breast cancer or for other
reasons has damage done to breasts and
then they're getting breast
reconstruction uh in order to get back
what they had that you see that is
different than someone who just says
here's 10 things i want to change
because i want to change the way I look
and I'm going at 10 surgeries or
procedures for example you see those two
differently yeah absolutely i think it's
all about appearance especially if it's
a result of some sort of burn or disease
that they have these ailments or
difference in appearance I think that's
really fine I also think that depending
on how much money is being spent might
it might opinion would be impacted but
not in terms of the absolute amount of
money if you have a lot of money
spending fifty thousand dollars on skype
cosmetic surgery may not represent a big
financial impact for you for me a
consideration in whether it feels like
this is starting to get a little bit
unhealthy is the relative expenditure
right if you're somebody that makes
twenty thousand dollars a year and has a
family and as kids and you're going out
and spending even eight thousand dollars
on a breast implants for example uh or a
number of other small procedures
regularly getting Botox and fillers as
well as a you know maybe getting hair
transplants whatever the case may be if
the relative amount of spending really
seems to be an amount that is
problematic for your budget and your
income that to me is also a red flag
that it may be taking on an unhealthy
direction yes and a good example of that
is the picture that we have behind us
because reportedly Donald Trump has
spent about sixty thousand dollars on
hair procedures and you know if it was
just anyone else I wouldn't mind it so
much but he seems to be so insecure with
his hair and his appearance that's why
he's he's doing these kind of so is this
why I'm guessing that Trump has denied
that he has a toupee and that appears to
be true but what you found is that it's
not a toupee but he that has had hair
transplantation several several and he's
even taking the anger out on his
ex-wife's when they call him out for the
painful procedures that he's undergone I
didn't know that I did not know that
that is fascinating uh okay so anyway I
don't think it is vain in principle to
spend money on cosmetic appearance but I
think that is really important to
consider ways in which it becomes
problematic and may be indicative of
sort of emotional distress that should
be dealt with directly rather than by
getting procedure after procedure